there is just something chemically  awesome about seeing these different  heroes interacting with each other for  the first time we need to go Avengers  age of Ultron introduce some new  characters within the body of that film  and Captain America's Civil War  introduced Black Panther then over the  course of his own movie we get to  explore in the world of what conduct  they see now I get to whose entire  technology is based on vibranium the  very rare very valuable material Captain  America shield is made from what Conda  opens up a whole new realm of  possibilities in terms of power in terms  of threats in terms of technology now  more than ever illusions of the vision  threaten our very existence there's so  many different characters and they're  moving in and out of these different  worlds all the different mythologies  I'll come together and play off each  other  you